Hello I'm Jens Bussman regional sales lead for Google Cloud in Germany, Austria and Switzerland.
The team and I support customers in the region.
We help customers adopt technologies to make their business competitive for the digital future.
Customers who are relying on us for this challenge are in all industries and of every size.
For example, our close partner SAP and also companies like REWE Digital, Klöckner, Kärcher,
and Sovanta AG, which is the first company to use SAP HANA and Netweaver on Google Cloud Platform.
For the past 18 months the demand for GCP services in the region has increased exponentially.
Our customers are looking forward to the start of the new cloud platform region in Frankfurt.
Frankfurt has the highest density of data centers in Germany.
This makes it the ideal location for customers to locate their cloud to provide the best possible performance.
The new region in Frankfurt means speed for customer workloads.
Our performance tests have shown a reduction in latency from 40% to 60%,
compared to other nearby cloud platform regions.
With the opening of the latest cloud platform in Frankfurt,
Google is your new neighbor, right next door.